alright i guess i guess we're alive
other way that one so welcome to the
apac enjoy hang office hour my name is
tony chen and I'm Android developer
advocate go ahead let me let my
colleagues introduce themselves lol this
is raj sleep I'm Android developer
advocate based out of India ok hello
everybody my name is Bill scam at sochi
i am developer advocate based in Tokyo
nice to meet you great um so let's take
a look at the question this week so I
think rajdeep you're going to take the
first question right yes just give me a
second yeah so the first question is
from a mogu had robot and the question
is try most all the OS released by
Android have a good task killer but
still in for dot 0 i see a lot of
battery lagging applications running in
background is there a way developers can
minimize the rapa consumption this
version ok so the question is can we
have a more effective way of producing
ramp consumption by using a task killer
so as far as we know after gingerbread
it's not possible to kill a task so even
if you kill a process in which an
application is running whether it's a
full-grown process or a background
process the process manager will try to
restart that process again even if you
kill it using your third party
application so so are based on the
understanding i have i think trying to
kill a process to optimize ram usage is
like a non-starter so other
developers need to look at other options
to optimize the ram that they are not
unnecessarily hitting the local database
or it in the network connection unless
they're killing me to data fetch data
locally or remotely great um so rusty by
think there's and also another question
I think probably missed earlier can you
take a look is from a location Sofia the
author of the author is a that dangly
wires so can you yeah I guess go all up
in my space heater so what is the best
way to retain and the store activity
states in a project with lots of big
forms so the best option is to create
use bundles its most partners which are
available when you when you're on
creator is called or on Scott is called
so these bundles are passed and when you
get when ondestroy scored you can
actually use these bundles to store
those activities now so that is like a
easier option so you also might want to
override this and store this in a local
database if the amount of data you have
is lot more and you want to implement an
alternate persistence mechanism you can
do that so now bundle is n built
mechanism provided by Android the only
thing is you need to override these
activity lifecycle methods and when the
activities are going in on pause or on
stop you need to call these and when
it's again restarting need to repopulate
those arms so so that's a short answer
to this question cool rasta I think you
have done expression okay and the next
question is um this is a question from
PETA in doubling
and my application uses asynctask for
ready loading the images in a listview
and I have recently seen an increase in
the number of rejected execution
exceptions any ideas on how best to
handle them reduce the frequency and
okay I I haven't seen you a code yet but
the there are I think there are possibly
two things happening here and the the
first of all I'd like to remind you that
a sync task is not designed for running
hundreds of hundreds of tasks at the
same time we have a certain number of
limitations in terms of simultaneous
execution of a sync task and the for
example in Gingerbread I I believe that
the limitation is the up to ten slits at
maximum and if you go beyond that and
you may get these rejected education
exceptions and the general thinking is
that i think task is designed for doing
some background task for updating user
interface at some later point in your
software and we do not expect hundreds
of hundreds of I think tasks lining up
for updating via user interface all over
the time so we have certain limitation
there and the in addition we do not want
this hundreds of tasks or maybe tens of
task of updating user interface randomly
that could generate really buddies
experience so i would like to remind you
that all of us should be really careful
in terms of scheduling asynctask into
the activities model number
of tasks rather than scheduling hundreds
of hundreds of tasks at the same time
having said that another big change we
did in Ice Cream Sandwich was that
before Ice Cream Sandwich I think test
was scheduled in parallel using general
federal executive and since ice cream
sandwich we stopped learning I think
tasks in parallel sleds instead we
started running I think tasks in single
spread outside the main you nice red and
the reason behind that was to avoid the
confusion in terms of updating user
interface at the same time this
multi-threaded programming in general is
really complex problem so we wanted to
simplify the problem by making single
shred executed at the default and you
can still choose multiple threads
executor by parameter for this I think
task and so that was a big change in Ice
Cream Sandwich and the but looking at
this question you say that you have
recently seen an increase in the number
of rejected education exceptions and I
do not know if this is happening in ICS
or if this is happening on maybe royal
or gingerbread on decent version of your
application and but the address to cause
I direct to the recommend that you
consider reducing the number of icing
tasks you execute at the same time and
the instead please consider maybe 10 or
possibly less I think tasks being
scheduled at the same time then you
should have master's program of rejected
execution of exceptions and the this I
think test
that if you have really hundreds of
hundreds of tests you should execute you
may want to implement your own some kind
of schedule but the it should not be
necessarily in ice cream sandwich but if
you are targeting gingerbread or royal
you may want to execute severely by
yourself and that was my suggestion and
I hope this answers your questions thank
you very much thank you ross k also i'll
take the next question so this question
is from rj hotel p from Omaha Nebraska
also the question was my apps uses the
audio record API the doc says several
rate of 44.1 calibers is guaranteed to
work on all devices while on several
phones the audio worker constructor
throws illegalstateexception our
disaster for simple wait or for the
vocal until words why so um I guess that
the answer to this question is um in
terms of guaranteed to work on all
devices I I believe that implies like
devices that passport the CTS test suite
we have um so it is possible on the
device devices are don't work may not be
one of the Android devices that pass our
compatibility test suite arm so if
that's not the case we encourage you to
send us a opposed to share with us the
model so maybe we can afford this to to
the vendor the OEMs and follow up on
that but in general the 44.1 kilo
present blu-ray is pretty common and
should be supported on all the Android
compatible devices
so our next question I guess is rusty
again okay the this is a question from
jb hemlock in shadow united states the
question is my application makes heavy
use of insight or an inept health system
this works in say two points too but it
doesn't work on my HTC one s running all
point or points 3 has anything changed
okay um to answer this question I am
sorry we do not really know the answer
to discussion and so I would recommend
you to contact HP g 1's manufacturer
because i have seen several reports very
similar reports from HTC one s users on
this program sorry about not as not
being able to answer this question ok um
mushy yes so the next question is from
ham debarred in india how to make a
spinner that drags down instead of
popping in a new window so the question
is instead of the spinner list of
popping up in a new separate window how
the guinness can be populated in the
same view now the behavior Richard you
are talking about that is a default
behavior and the only way to implement a
new behavior is that you should
implement your own spinner and overwrite
the draw method of canvas so that you
can add your own views there or the way
you want your spinner output to look
like because there is no way to extend
the current spinner and alternate the
rendering mechanism right so so the best
option is to go ahead and write your own
spinner you might want to take a look at
the current implementation of the
spinner which is anywhere open source
and sees few methods like Andhra which
you can override and implement the way
you want it ok so that's the answer to
this question the next question also is
from the same developer why android
doesn't give a widget for choosing an
item from a list of play with a widget
similar to date picker ok it would be
very helpful yeah that's a pretty nice
suggestion and thanks for posting a
thicker will us on this feedback to our
frame working for android so that you
can took her take a look at this
suggestion and possibly implemented
depending on the priority and another
reschedule so so Tony over to you yeah
thank you um so the next question is
coming from alejandro um so the question
was i'm working with a google maps api
vacation and I'm trying to figure out
how to display a route from X to Y any
recommendation I just start started with
Android development so um so basically
there are two approach to this to this
question so we have a map native API in
android but unfortunate us know are no
easy way to wrap our 22 route to touro
pretty much you have to use a tutorial
on your own shapes and and using the the
direction AVR the death or the
coordinates and map it to pixels and
draw and draw the lines with shapes oh
but you can the other option is using
webview are using
the map Web API and I with the map API
Web API it does go by polylines so so it
probably make it easier for you to draw
routes using the web api using a web
view but there may be some performance I
con some trade off so using webview so
this really depends on your application
but that's pretty much how how how you
approached the problem um the next
question is from general of a map
Argentina so the question was how do i
use the annex s expansion file why
upload updating an apk in the developer
console so generous sure without a swing
shot of showing the newer version of APK
cannot use an old version of the
expansion file um so Gerald my answer to
your question is um we are we were able
to reproduce the what your look of what
you saw and so I think it's either um
there's a an error in our documentation
or or this is just simply how are the
expansion valve is always behaving so I
will ask this back to the to the
engineering team men and and final
whether this is a buck or there's an
error in the documentation so thank you
for bringing this up to us we will
update a documentation or power but
correspondingly thank you so um I guess
the last question rusty take away yes so
the last question is from the key in
Bangor in here well the question is
how how to update the position of a
button or image after translate
animation is done so yes did a bunch of
steps which are not working so the
answer to this question depends on the
version of Android you are running after
honeycomb we came out with new property
and object animation framework so you
should use that to do the animation so
you might want to look at view animation
framework which is older preamble but i
am not really sure whether this will
work there or not and if you can provide
more details about our link to a code in
our next office odds you can you know
provide a more detailed response I based
on the current question I would say if
you're looking at android three dot zero
or above use the property animation
otherwise please send us your code and
we'll take a look cool thanks a lot um I
think we are always our work welcome to
UM to get exciting like questions from
you guys and we'll try our best to find
answers for you and so don't hesitate to
us you can either post it on our Google+
page or we can or even place send it two
hours individual gmail account haha Tony
done actually I got the follow-up
question okay gplus comments and this is
a question from attic videos and the
question is pointer is not true in
asynctask and the answer is that we do
have to in sync task and it is true in
Gingerbread and the ICS as well and the
the thing is that the maximum length of
cured very limited before ICS and the
the discrimination won't be
of the consideration that i think task
shouldn't really be used to schedule
hundreds of hundreds of tasks that could
confuse user interface and so the in ICS
before the behavior if everything is
actually killed into single Elaine and
then executed sequentially so in ICS and
in Gingerbread adware and we are heavily
using q mechanism everywhere in a sink
task I hope this answers your question
thank you cool sorry about that is a
flowing of that roster um I guess that's
pretty much all the questions we have
for this week and thank you for watching
and we hope to see you guys soon okay
look okay thank you thank you very much
all right thank you